in z et voici lagerfeld du destin des
germains la mode une france ils
balancent tout y passe et à des lakas
s'est plus senti portrait chinois du
germano suédois karl lagerfeld bonsoir
bonsoir
alors tu as dit en france on m'appelle
l'horrible allemand et en allemagne
celui qui est parti alors j'aimerais
avoir tout en doute même cette semaine
tes réactions sur la victoire de la
droite en rda que tu as dit que j'en
avais dit que les allemands de l'est
avaient voté avec leurs ventres c'est
très facile quand on va tous les jours
chez lipp de dire des choses pareilles
nous approchons quand même il avait pas
manger très très très bien depuis très
longtemps
il n'y a pas que leur ventre parce que
leur système économique qui câline 0,12
qui a su passer là pendant 40 ans et
plus c'était nul déjà du temps des nazis
l'industrie s'était pas tellement génial
dans cette partie de d'hernani parce que
c'était jamais la vraie malle arrière
chose industriel l'industrie sylvie qui
est polonais maintenant et l'autre par
exemple moi je connais beaucoup
d'industriels allemands à qui on propose
désigne alors six usines dans la main
des lettres ne valent pas un clou ces
dérives de vidéos et tout est à
reconstruire
malheureusement c'est encore l'argent
qui reconstruit ce n'est pas lady du
logis est ce que tu crois que les
français ont le tort ou à raison d'avoir
peur de la réunification de l'allemagne
non c'est au contraire pour un certain
temps je pense même que ça va
économiquement affaiblir l'allemagne la
marque donc arrangé fait aussi des
affaires des autres
je pense qu'en cet instrument qu'il
retrouvera tout le monde croit des
affaires tout le monde
trouvera un nouveau marché et puis vous
avez l'allemagne ça n'est plus
l'allemagne de lui tant de la preuve il
a demandé terre faites-le pour venir un
premier nul part et d'un europe c'est
avec cette absurde une ovation alors je
n'ai pas avoir réussi par sa famille est
originaire de hambourg le mans psg au
point qu'ils ont traversées comment ta
famille la deuxième guerre mondiale
the jets j'ai eu de la chance prime aux
états unis en 1938
je m'en souviens très bien de la guerre
c'est comme s'il n'avait pas eu lieu
parce que mon père avait eu la bonne
idée pour une auto qui avait différents
d'acheter une propriété la frontière
danoise
juste avant la guerre et j'ai passé mon
enfance des premiers donner d'eux m'a
mis dans cette reprise et à la frontière
danoise où s'est rien passé monté par an
et est très riche
tout est une question de prix oui il
s'est quand même propriétaire entre le
dreff les coriaces
l'argent n'est pas tout il faut
s'intégrer bonheur comme on dit ça peut
aider mais je pense que faire confiance
à ces enfants qu'on puisse faire est
qu'on a envie de faire
même si ça corresponde pas aux idées de
tes parents c'est le plus grand de ce
monde l'aura 14 ans qui est venu à paris
pour pour vous faire des études habiter
à l'hôtel d'ailleurs non une un truc
pour étudier en outre très bien je
trouve ça génial pour lui c'est
incroyable que je regarde deux enfants
des 14 15 ans et je me dit comment je
faisais moi pour lui de tout seul comme
l'udc alors la saison je fais un
concours organisé par le comité
international de la laine et tu as fait
un petit manteau en cheville au john
incroyablement en civil ont envahi la
préhistoire
c'est l'histoire de la loi dans tous les
grades oui c'est une chose d'un croc la
gagner le concours enfin ex-aequo avec
saint laurent comme bien des revues
avait une robe contre nous j'étais
jaloux de saint-laurent quand il était
ici car vingt ans avant tout appareil
c'est un sentiment que j'ignore et je
n'ai fait rien par rapport aux autres je
ne fais des choses que par rapport à moi
il ya une styliste anglaise que je vais
tendre autre que j'aime beaucoup qui m'a
dit un jour n'est pas qu'au père n'ait
pas compris il a sauvé les vices dans la
ville est ce que tu es sensibles
critiques quand on dit par exemple
carlos est un excellent metteur en scène
mais c'est pas un novateur ou des choses
comme ça je te salue tout ça n'est pas
rigide et que les projets les critiques
et à petit personnes dans le monde dont
les critiques mais tout le reste c'est
naze opinion alors ta carrière a été
assistant d'abord chez balmain ou bien
commencé c'est très bien ensuite été
directeur artistique chez patou une
styliste chez chloé et dernièrement bien
sûr sauveur de chanel tout le monde le
sait sauf leur sauveur sauveur il faut
pas non plus oublier oui mais enfin je
veux dire ça a été aussi sauvé si tout a
été en danger parce que le propre et dia
de chanel a mis l'audi derrière ce qu'il
fallait
parce qu on ne sauve pas uniquement
après dans un chili 110 dollars on a
pris six stylistes et maintenant ça va
marcher tout seul alors tu dessines
combien de modèles par an à peu près 30
jamais ce que tu fais les planes modèle
disent on est là au moins on parle de
1700 parents quand même eu ce que ça
plus ça vous arrive vous avez vous pensé
aussi tout ce qui va à la poubelle
oui est-ce que je n'utilise pas et puis
entre les collections allemand mes
collections italiennes et tout le reste
ça doit faire beaucoup plus je ne compte
pas pour moi
dessiner essayez travailler dans ce
métier c'est devenu
une source naturelle comme respirateur
car il ya les parfums en plus et les
accessoires et tu as dit un jour cardin
maintenant c'est devenu un marchand de
soupe est ce que t'as pas peur à force
de faire plein de licences comme ça de
film on peut tabler à plein de dix ans
comme ça je n'ai pas envie d'avoir
restaurant sécurisé puisque les temps ni
dans l'alimentaire dans l'alimentaire
j'ai pas envie retourner alors ça n'a
pas empêché évidemment de connaître une
une réussite exceptionnelle tu es riche
et célèbre
on va commencer par la richesse et à
combien de maisons aujourd'hui
d'appartement bon je sais pas moi comme
je suis un décorateur frustrés ils
savent pas combien tu dessines de
modèles je vais bien pouvoir mais les
maisons tout le bien de se voir
l'analyse âgées dans ce chantier qui
dynamita appartement à paris
il faut bien que le biais des modèles
habituels ou tel critère d'électricité
que tout était là je travaille dans une
pièce avant tout une pièce à rome tu as
d'un grand atelier la de quartier où il
y avait beaucoup d'ateliers de 4 danois
au 19e siècle et a appartenu à acheter
l'atelier de 3,21 à un moment donné à
new york comme tous les secteurs mais ça
j'y vais jamais je n'ai pas beaucoup de
new york à hambourg
quelque chose en bauges et maison
sublime qui est d'ailleurs j'ai donné à
la ville l'aven ma vie elle est la vie
parce que c'est un monument historique
très très très bizarre qui n'est pas
fait pour ta grandchamp son manoir
l'angleterre et que j'ai hérité mais j'y
vais jamais l'année dernière j'étais je
crois 48 heures mais pour moi cette
année c'est cet habitué de l'endroit
l'essentiel cela existe un match
physique je dois faire et c'est un
chantier très habitable budget
j'ai tout l'arraché à l'intérieur et pas
encore eu le temps de refaire on s'est
presque inhabitables je peux même pas y
toucher
pâques est une pièce avec ses 25 mètres
de long qui rempli de livres c'est vrai
oui bizarre
aller des barrages à monaco tu as quoi
l'autre bout d'un moment j'ai posé par
hasard plusieurs choses de cette fameuse
villa qui resterait qui est inoccupé
pendant les visites et la vigie que tu
connais d'ailleurs
et puis j'ai aussi un appartement que
quand je vais avec moins de monde que
vous êtes tout seul à côté du palais qui
était dans une maison ancienne refaite
c'est là qu'ils les 700 mètres 41e étage
je n'ai changé il est moins grand sud
arrêt il a plus de charme parce que
jamais mieux puisque le syndicat bsa
mètres carrés sur une tournée qu'amusant
il fait même fiche mais c'était dans une
maison nouvelle évidemment jamais
habiter la maison triomphe de la maison
cirque amar c'est ça mais ça dépendra
comme à la maison de retraite avec
l'ascenseur pour la même que les usa
mais il faut dans l'intérêt bien trop
lourd pour j'ai perdu 15 kilos peut-être
demain on peut pas monter ensemble comme
moi ou la voiture mais pas les deux tu
as dit aucune des sociétés pour
lesquelles je travaille ne m'appartient
c'est ça ton système actuellement sur le
visage des royalties exactement partir
de pourcentage ou ce qu'on appelle des
flèches fille mais je ne veux jamais
être concerné par tout ce qui est
gestion à faire je veux garder un
sentiment de liberté totale et que tout
ce que je fais je le fais parce que je
veux bien mais parce que tu es obligé de
le faire et pour moi c'est très
important
alors tu arrives tu célèbres c'est à
dire que y'a des gens enfin il ya des
sondages qui ont été créés sur canton de
vaud avec ton quatre cantons les ventes
a été l'une est allée battre
non mais on dit on sait pas très bien ce
qu'il fait mais on sait que c'est karl
lagerfeld et ça c'est une bonne chose
oui c'est très bien qu'ils arrivaient à
apposer une image médiatique où il est
très fort à une chose qui a été moins
médiatiquement par les cinq minutes
c'est la sphère inès de la fressange
raciale
une affaire que la tienne enfin tu
disais en 87 c'est un peu ma fille si
j'ai signé avec chanel c'est aussi parce
que elle est là c'est la française aidée
à l'un de ces problèmes c'est malheureux
ce qu'est et n'a jamais pu s'imposer à
l'étranger en allemagne en numérique qui
font des marchés importants personnel
son impact est ténue non seulement parce
que tu disais c'est la française idéal
puis le jour elle été choisie comme la
française idéal c'est à dire pour
incarner mariale ce qui effectivement
autorisé
là tu t'énerves et a dit non non c'est
bourgeois c'était hier au zénith
bourgeois ni vulgaire c'était au fait
oui pour dire gentiment à quelqu'un
puisqu'après madame a dit que j'étais
jolie de l'état pour lui dire c'était
plus interdire ça que didier ma portée
je pense que de temps pour être
mannequin s'est passé dans ce que tu dis
qu'elle était bourgeoisement fins appel
quand même 2 la fressange et ne veulent
pas fun lagerfeld il ya par titre en
suède dans les téléphones donc ton père
était baron oui plus tard c'est sûr
qu'avec et heather quand même et ça je
ne suis pas contre c'est pas moi qui
allais qui m'appelle comme ça c'est
fairchild donc je ne peux rien
tu penses que c'était mauvais pour
chanel qu'elle se fie aux anges dans sa
salle de bains son côté gauche caviar
mais maintenant elle est complètement
prochaine elle n'était plus une
optionnelle maintenance et des années 90
et c'est fini maintenant c'est claudia
schiffer c'est autre chose que le site n
aura jamais un contrat comme elle a eu
parce que nico claudia c'est bien ni
personnel parce que je pense que
finalement les matchs pour pas qu'ils
attachent une fille cachée très années
80 mais non c'est quelque chose
maintenant
2 les gars je n'aiderai plus jamais un
mannequin de la même façon comme je les
ai aidés est ce parce que l'ingratitude
à ce degré a ses limites et à théo
colère toujours quand je voudrais tu ne
bat contre la monnaie japonaise alors
par contre est au mieux avec les monaco
a été très ami de la famille de monaco
c'est vrai que tu corresponds
journellement avec le prince rainier
montrent ce fossé pas de pouvoir de lomé
où il a autre chose à faire par contre
quand on lis dans la presse que tu
trouves le prince albert très spirituel
s'est dit c'est vrai je la connais il
est très drôle ah bon donc ça tu confies
en passant c'est très amusant
il a une grande honte d'imitateur et
acteur qui est absurde mais connue mais
on trouve très très distrayant alors tu
as dit une phrase que je trouve très
très drôle dit dans le fond je m'en sors
pas mal parce qu'un bon âge pour être
pathétique parce que ouais je me pose
pas trop de questions à notre sujet
ouais tu veux qu'on joue un jeu là ça
dépend des jeux
c'était d une injure
colas très violente comme ça qui
éclaterait la seule coupe qui durerait
longtemps quand même je ne sais pas
vraiment rancunier mais j'ai beaucoup de
patience c'était une maladie ou
contagieuse
c'est très fragile à ce qu'il fit il
fait très mal de gros bourdon année
c'est ça ce serait qui alors pourquoi
parce qu'on peut le faire
vous faites tous les deux visions avec
les femmes quand même c'est sur ma page
et les exploitations pinceau dit c'est
clair c'était un dictateur
c était un dictateur frédéric ii de
prusse total de 6 était un vice mais une
discipine négative si tu étais univers
dans mon métier évidemment une guerre en
dentelles fait ben whishaw un poison
je serai un poison nantes